bitcoin's price has been dropping
aggressively over the last eight months
or so now of course it's important first
let's zoom out if we go ahead and we
zoom out what we can see here on the
price is that bitcoin is up a lot over a
long period of time but again over the
last eight months you can see that
bitcoin has fallen from 69 000 back in
november all the way today to about 23
300
now many people are worried about the
price and they should be that's the
thing that moves on a day-to-day basis
but there is a difference between price
and value price is the thing that people
are willing to trade on a daily basis
but value is actually what is going to
hold over the long period of time if
it's a good asset during these times
when price is falling it's always
important to re-evaluate your investment
thesis is bitcoin as an open source
decentralized digital currency with a
programmatic monetary policy and a
finite supply still valuable or has that
value come down with price if it hasn't
that just means that price and value are
diverging and ultimately it's
undervalued but that is important to
actually go look at the underlying
fundamentals before we can make that
conclusion so let's jump right in and
take a first look at hash rate with the
hash rate what we can see is that it has
quadrupled over the last three years
this shows that bitcoin is more secure
today than it has been ever before if we
then take a look at the average
transaction fee paid on layer 1 of
bitcoin we can see that today it's under
a dollar and 50 cents that means that it
is incredibly cheap to go ahead and make
very large transfers of value but more
importantly you can see back in 2017
there was a huge spike in fees when
bitcoin hit an all-time high at 20 000
and then in q1 and q2 of 2021 the first
time we hit a new all-time high we saw a
big spike in fees as well but as you'll
notice from this chart as we entered
into the latter half of 2021 even though
price went back and hit a new all-time
high of 69 000 there was no large
increase in fees that's because there's
been tons of innovation on layer one and
also a very large rise in the adoption
of the lightning network then if we take
a look at the on-chain distribution of
bitcoin we can see that there are wallet
addresses holding .01 bitcoin point one
bitcoin and one bitcoin all hitting
all-time highs these small players in
the bitcoin market they continue to
dollar cost average they continue to
suck up economic value and it's actually
the whales the large holders of bitcoin
that are selling well the little guys
the plebs they're the ones who are
buying up all that bitcoin then we can
take a look at long-term versus
short-term holders and will clemente
pointing out that we are watching the
short-term holder cost bases actually
drop at the same time the long-term
holder cost basis is rising historically
when these two things have crossed and
the short-term holder cost basis has
gone below the long-term holder cost
basis it has signaled a very very
attractive price point next up we can
look at transaction metrics and when we
look here at the active addresses we can
see that even though price has been
drawing down the number of active
addresses is still in line and within
the range that we have seen historically
the same is also true of the number of
transactions on the network as well we
continue to see the number of
transactions showing right within that
same exact range we can see here that
the number of transactions continue to
show right within that historical range
as well
next up we can take a look at the
percent of bitcoin in circulating supply
that's in profit we're now under 52 of
bitcoin in circulation actually in
profit that may seem low compared to
historical norms but unfortunately
usually we see under 50 percent in bear
markets and so somewhere in that 40 to
45 range something to keep an eye out
and then lastly the lightning network
capacity continues to reach all-time
high levels as well and it just seems to
be growing like a weed up and to the
right
now of course nobody knows what's going
to happen the federal reserve is in
control right now they are tanking asset
prices across markets by raising
interest rates and conducting
quantitative tightening
all assets are one trade at the moment
but what is important for you as an
investor to do is take a look at what's
happening with the price be aware of it
pay attention to it but also understand
what the underlying fundamentals are are
you actually seeing the fundamentals
degrade are they getting worse or is
this simply price diverging from the
value of an asset now of course when i
go and i re-evaluate i revisit my
investment thesis over the weekend i
come to the same conclusion bitcoin is
not only continuing to be adopted it's
not only doing exactly what it was
supposed to do but it's actually
reaching all-time highs and a number of
these underlying fundamentals that makes
me very confident that bitcoin is still
in the exact same place that it was
before the price started to fall now the
price could go down more or maybe not i
don't know what's going to happen but
what i do know is that price and value
seem to be diverging and if you're a
long-term holder you simply want to
understand what the value of the asset
is not necessarily the price i hope this
is helpful as you continue to break down
bitcoin and what you're going to do over
the coming months but understand the
difference between price and value is
important in every asset and bitcoin is
no different hey you did you like this
video great we make five of them a day
and post them here on this channel make
sure you subscribe like the video and
see you next time